[Music]
police arrested Major League managers
for playing baseball on a Sunday in 1917
thousands of soldiers were in New York
City ready to sail for Europe the next
day so they could attend the Giants and
reds moved up their scheduled match to
Sunday and pledged the proceeds to the
Troops after the game the managers were
arrested New York's blue laws forbade
playing baseball on the Sabbath judge
Frank McCade a rabid Giants fan was
incensed he quickly dismissed the case
and spent the next year personally
campaigning to have the ban overturned
by 1919 the law had changed and judge
mcade threw out the ceremonial pitch at
New York's first officially sanctioned
Sunday contest yes this really happened